[Music]
hello and welcome to quad Riga what
began is a New York Times report about
the misdeeds of one middle-aged man has
become a worldwide outcry as women
around the world take to social media to
disclose the harassment and abuse that
they have faced at the center of the
storm is the all-powerful Hollywood film
producer Harvey Weinstein following
allegations of sexual harassment
including rape by dozens of women
recounting acts that go back decades the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences which Awards the Oscars
expelled mr. Weinstein with the words
that sexually aggressive behavior in the
film industry is over but is it really
the millions of women who have told
their stories on social media under the
hashtag me to describe a pervasive
pattern that transcends cultures and
epochs weather and how that pattern can
be broken is what we want to discuss
today on quadriga
sexism male perpetrators female victims
that's our title here our guests it's a
pleasure to welcome Stephanie Lowe house
she is founder and co-editor of the
german-language Missy magazine which is
dedicated to covering pop politics and
feminism
she says sexist comments are part of a
rape culture they're intended to keep
women in their place and undermine them
and it's a pleasure to welcome via
Katella she is an author and freelance
columnist who writes frequently on
gender topics she says how often do we
as women sell ourselves prostitute
ourselves willingly and
opportunistically because it's useful to
say me two years later is too little and
it's a pleasure to have Alan Posner with
us on the show once again he's a
commentator for the German daily
newspaper de Velde
and he says it has been well said that
men fear women because they might laugh
at them whereas women fear men because
they might kill them
let's start out by taking a look at this
pattern that is coming to light in the
wake of the revelations about Harvey
Weinstein and the fact is just in the
past 10 days nearly 2 million women from
85 countries have shared their stories
of sexual assault and/or harassment
under this hashtag me too and I'm going
to get just a little bit personal for a
moment and that pattern definitely is
familiar to me as a young lawyer and a
young journalist I experienced sexual
harassment both in an interview
situation one of my very first
interviews as a young lawyer and also on
assignment when I was traveling with
people who were my male bosses so just
let me briefly ask the two of you have
you had such experiences similar
experiences Stephanie laughs well
definitely before I became a journalist
I was working in the technical field and
I had some experience especially with
customers not so much with with my
colleagues they were actually quite
feminist but with customers that
couldn't deal with the fact that I was a
woman dealing with technical things and
they were really I don't know they were
sexist telling me why didn't you become
a teacher but such a pretty girl
and after being sexist to me for like
telling me sexist comments for 30
minutes or more they were they were
trying to invite me to dinner so I'm so
I've made this experience and in
journalism not so much because I'm
working with women a lot so we don't
have that problem but it actually made
me sort of changed my profession because
I was thinking if I want this for the
rest of my life or not
Yoga Keller yes I think every woman has
experienced things like this me myself I
worked as a waitress when I was a
student so and I think every waitress
knows bad behavior by man and it was
different you know I could also make a
difference between the customers over
there and my colleagues and my bosses
they always protected as girls as
waitresses
so it's we have men like this and we
have men like this not but I think every
woman has to tell a story and the two of
you in that experience did you did you
experience feel fear or feel threatened
did it limit your choices you talked
about not staying in that field would
you and you would say that had that
limitation had to do with this I wasn't
afraid but I got really really angry I
was so angry and I was crying with anger
I didn't know what to do I thought that
we didn't have a problem with sexism
anymore and I was really young and I
don't know like it was my first
experience it was so graphic and after
what's thinking back I can think of more
stuff that I didn't want to notice at
that time that weren't as obvious but it
made me angry and it's part of why I
started a feminist magazine actually
baby-killer no no I I don't look back
with bad feelings you know because I
never felt like I can't do anything or
so so it's it was just them III for me
it was bad behavior by man but I also
had bad behavior by women and I always
felt protected by other men too at the
same moment so so I can't say that I am
looking back with bad feelings and with
this aim to change something I think
what what made me so angry was the fact
that I felt objectified I felt like
nobody cares about what I know what I
can do what's in my brain but I was
totally reduced to my female features
and to my looks and and that what made
me so angry I have to confess that I
felt fear I was alone in a room in all
three of these incidents and didn't
really see what kind of recourse I would
have but maybe we can come back to that
a little later let me ask Alan Posner
now when you hear about these many many
many tales that are coming out would you
say you're surprised at this at the
extent we're hearing from a lot of men
who say wow I never realized
this widespread does that apply to you
well I think probably like most men yes
and no because on the one hand you're
shocked I mean if you famous and
powerful women can be preyed upon in in
in in in a very liberal society that
Hollywood is in America is in this way
you're shocked at the same time you say
in a way you knew it you knew it you
didn't know it you didn't want to know
and the very fact that as a man we're
constantly pushing this out of our
consciousness is part of the problem the
fact that you can go on although you
actually know it and you know I'm a son
of a mother I'm a husband of a wife and
father of a daughter and a grandfather
to two granddaughters it is not
something which is apart from me and yet
I do it and that's part of the problem
because before I became a journalist I
was a teacher and it's an open secret
that in all of the schools in Germany
girls are harassed by male teachers it's
an open secret it happens every day as
we speak this is happening and these are
not people who are being protected
they're being subjected to humiliation
by people who then give them marks for
their papers or whatever who who have
the power to control their futures who
can make them look silly who can do this
coup who can do that in many cases it's
ten girls to go home if they're from
patriarchal families for instance Muslim
girls who then get even worse
stuff when they go home so so we know it
and and and and unless I'm a you know
really actually doing what you do
working all the time to sort of expose
and deal with it and give people self
consciousness then I shove it to the
other compartment of a mind and deal
with you know I don't know how many
immigrants are vegan is it gonna be
200,000 or 100,000 yeah so that's the
problem if you look back for yourself in
light of this discussion would you say
there are incidences where you feel you
yourself have behaved improperly oh yes
oh yes
as a teacher towards
students not in you know not in a
criminal sentence but in even the way I
thought about them you know it it's a
double bind for women in for girls in
the school if they're pretty you know
the people are gonna say oh she gets his
good no good microphone to you because
she's teacher's pet she's pretty it's
the truth it's not of a truth but it's
not the truth actually or if it is that
bad enough so I mean there's you know
I've when I even when I was a student I
was in the school which was progressive
and they were very proud of being
progressive and there was a and we said
we've sat on the teachers board when
they discussed things that went on in
this school is reform school and there
were there was a girl she had a name
someone could make it and someone said
that the teacher said of her she's boy
crazy it happened actually to be a girl
that I was in love with it the time
instead of standing up okay I was only
16 and banging on the table I just felt
ashamed but you know these teachers you
know and it's going on it was that that
was in the 60s
and is still going on shame of course is
a common denominator in so many of these
stories let's take a closer look at the
pattern that we're talking about and it
certainly is one that is not confined to
the world of entertainment nor to the
United States what the stories that
we're hearing transcend cultures and
they transcend epochs so let's recall a
few examples from the political sphere
gorillas in the wild they're known as
alpha males
US President Donald Trump probably
considers himself one in a conversation
with the journalist caught on tape he
said it didn't hurt his campaign Trump
won the election and became president
gorilla a different time different style
in the 1990s US President Bill Clinton's
affair with a White House intern caused
a sensation Clinton sought to quash the
scandal by denying the allegation
I did not have sexual relations with
that woman miss Lewinsky efforts to
impeach the then president failed his
wife Hillary Clinton week was glad for
his public support during the 2016
presidential race gorilla but his
actions plainly went too far
Dominique strauss-kahn former head of
the International Monetary Fund he was
arrested in the US for allegedly raping
a hotel maid soon other assault
accusations came to light in the end
there were few legal consequences for
him men abusing power where's the
backlash you could kill if I go back to
your opening statement you say that
women go along because they hope to get
something out of these sexual encounters
aren't you blaming the victim no no I
just I think this is just part of the
truth that we also have especially when
you have a look to Hollywood you know if
you earn your money by just presenting
yourself and your your body then people
watch just watch your body
we have those women who just sell
themselves and it's okay
you know if they do it because they want
to it's okay that's it's not a moral
thing but we have to realize that we
also have those women who don't have a
problem with all this and that's so that
makes this discussion so so so difficult
because on one hand we have those women
who were forced and we have the other
women too and it's it's it's very and I
think on at the beginning of a
discussion we have to divide all this
because not only man can be sexist but
we're also women just who like to play
these those games profit from it the
young women in the case of mr. Weinstein
many of them weren't even acting yet
they were looking for their first
opportunity I don't talk about mr.
Weinstein I talk about other women here
for example take those bunnies in
in the mention of Hugh Hefner weather
forced to do things like this to live
there to Lovato Walker
yes but you know you can as a woman you
can you can take another job nobody is
forced to be a bunny in dimension of you
have no but we have women in this world
who have no problem with I would like to
admit more analytical perspective I mean
there's this word that I actually kind
of like but it's really old-school
patriarchy so of course in patriarchy we
have women find their way around if they
want to gain power and this means of
course I mean we know for example there
were recent study in Germany that it's
easier for women to become rich by
marrying them by working because it's
still easier for them to to do that and
this is part of it's wrong that they do
it no I don't want to know but it's
wrong that the system is like is this
and what feminism and what we should
talk a bit about is how to change this
patriarchal system because nobody should
have to marry or yeah you know undress
just to become to get up in society I
mean you know so I'm so this is it's not
it's not an excuse because it is like
this I mean we still need to talk about
the violence the sexual harassment and
we shouldn't derail it by talking about
I ask you about that point about the
violence because your opening statement
talked about rape culture and said that
men use assault to keep women down but
in many many of these cases we're not
really talking about the exercise of
physical power so much as economic power
aren't we well I think that all these
sorts of discrimination like sexism bus
but also racism and things like this
they all I mean the underlying thing is
a power distribution in society and
power and money in capitalism is sort of
a similar thing you know the more money
you have the more power you have so I
mean the more powerful the the Weinstein
shows a very man who's very powerful and
who was able to keep up a system
systematic sexual harassment in order
because he was so powerful not every man
can do this so
the what's common the commonality
between sexual violence harassment and
verbal sexism is the same it's making
women feel unsecure like it worked with
me in the workplace but of course
there's a difference in the outcome or
in the effect it has
Alan Posner does that resonate with you
would you say we live in a rape culture
worldwide it's certainly true I mean
look at India look at the Arab world and
the point is the people I mean Birgit
hasn't mentioned this but in many of her
pieces she tries to make it a difference
between these two things you can you can
see with with Bill Clinton the point
about Bill Clinton actually wasn't the
mr. madoski that the point with him was
Paula Jones he had a woman brought to
him by straight state troopers to his
hotel room and then wanted to force her
to have sex with him it's obvious that
Bill Clinton has something to do with
the rape culture which we know from
India which we know from the Arab world
the whole point is that this is the tip
of a global iceberg which we
occasionally seen in the case like
Harvey Weinstein or in in that every day
we're gonna raped here and there raped
not only by men of color their rape out
by their their raped by their fathers by
the stepfathers by their uncles by their
friends of their uncle's by the Friends
of their mothers happens every day
in families all over Germany in that
I've worked myself into position where I
give you the word after that but we're
essentially talking about the degree of
choice that women face and also what
constitutes duress force so let us
briefly hear a statement from a woman
who was a victim of sexual abuse in the
workplace but I quit pursuing acting as
a career I have told parts of this story
to only a very few people over the years
I felt so powerless I didn't think
anyone would believe I was nobody
why would they so Buick eller what would
you have advised her to do differently
is there really a scenario where she
doesn't emerge as a victim with her
choices circumscribed you know I don't
know exactly now this case from from
just this few seconds but I think that
we have to make a difference in which
culture and in which law system you live
you know I think that a woman in a
Western world has much more
opportunities to do something she has
much more power because she has and now
by with she has so much help to get the
law system is on her side so so she can
get help and I think this is the
different we have to make being you
mentioned it already we have countries
in the world where we really have a rape
culture where you as a woman you don't
have the opportunity where you have men
who don't even do something wrong
because in their country it's by law
what they are doing and that's the thing
I I mentioned that we we have an
immigration at the moment at in Germany
from men from those countries who don't
know how to - how can say how to be with
with a moment in Germany because they
are socialized in countries and in
cultures where they just treat women bad
and they don't even feel wrong so we
have to keep with this okay staying with
the best-case-scenario of the Western
legal systems Stephanie Lowe house in
cases like Weinstein or like the Fox
News anchor Bill O'Reilly women did
bring legal complaints and what happened
is that there were settlements big legal
settlements some women one woman got as
much as 30 million we have just heard
this week from Bill O'Reilly they then
signed non-disclosure agreements these
women that they would not talk about the
story is that the right way for the
legal system to work in these cases or
does that simply allow this pattern to
continue this is
really not the right way I mean it's
very you as American the German legal
system is very different but also what
we have in Germany here is that for
example a lot of cases are brought up
but the rate of perpetrators who are
actually if you have some competitive
face and penalty is very small which is
because all these crimes are very often
very private and there are no witnesses
so it's very hard to prove that this
crime occurred and so I mean even though
I don't think you can you can change
this whole problem problem with the
legal system because because of this
yeah because of this idea that is a good
idea that we have to prove if someone is
guilty so but what we need is actually a
different culture and I think we should
talk a lot more about a prevention how
do we this is what I'm missing that of
course is the reason behind the me to
movement there has been a very strong
statement from both of the women who
were essentially image originators of
this saying we hope that more women
telling their stories will begin to
change things
Alan Posner when you have encountered
sexism harassment have you spoken out in
some way there was that whole discussion
about donald trump's locker room talk if
you've heard really egregious locker
room talk have you said something about
it I would probably say no I think
Donald Trump's quite right when he says
that men when they're amongst themselves
talk like that
and even you know softy progressive bla
bla men like myself I'm in a rock group
it's like football kind of yeah there's
that kind of talk going on and I don't
see anything and of course it spills
over into the way you treat women are
you you can't compartmentalize it and
you know it's it's there it's true and
that's why I think it's so disgraceful
that you should defend it quite frankly
I think we should be much more
self-critical and we actually need help
from women to sort of to come out as men
and say not say are women are just as
bad or women bring it upon themselves or
their cell
their bodies in Hollywood which is
stupid I mean or it if women are in a
structural situation where the choice
between remaining poor poor without a
job whatever or an ax menial job or
possibly advancing results by by by
demeaning themselves at the same time
you can't accuse the women of taking
advantage of that you have to accuse the
system and you have to change it and
people like yourself who's simply you're
simply going on the surface you know of
course there are women who prostitute
themselves
does that make prostitution good no it's
you know but you have my self I don't I
don't want to defend this behavior but I
just realized that it exists and that
there are women whose to tell me it's my
right to do this and and actually the
feminist movement has has has worked for
this that a woman can do this visit
without being told you are a [ __ ] for
this so we had we just have to realize
also in this in this discussion that
there are women showing behavior we
don't like or we don't understand but
they do it and it's their right to so so
you can't tell me it is it's a disgrace
for all women ask this those women if
they disgrace themselves at a fifth day
if they think for themself maybe this
really is you know you're you can't you
can't you can't different tell it or not
we need to talk about more and this is
what is missing in society is the
condoms consensus principle that
something is a crime and something is an
assault and something is violence when
it is not consensual so and I think this
is something that we need to learn in
sexuality and in we need different
sexual education so that we all know
what we're talking about let me take us
to the future very briefly because we
are almost out of time do you think that
this massive public outcry more women
talking will change things I know that
you have said in some of your writings
you think that it's
of hysteria you also said in your
opening statement me too is too little
so you don't expect anything to change
no no III don't think I think in one
year or in two years we will have the
next discussion on the same topic again
yeah I disagree actually I think that
one hashtag campaign of course doesn't
is not going to change anything but what
I've noticed from like making this
magazine since 2008 is that the
discussion has changed I think it's a
very different discussion that event the
discussion we had with hashtag Alf sky
with in 2013 and it's actually I think
we're going a little bit deeper and I
think more men are into the discussion
in 2013 I was all the time explaining
the difference between a compliment and
now we're talking about structural
sexism Alan Posner we've seen a rash of
firings in sectors from food to fashion
to finance just yesterday fidelity
letting two senior people go
uber let its head go is that a sign that
things are changing it's a reaction it's
good you need more than firing you need
hiring I mean you need quotas in all you
know learning political parties in
Parliament's and in the executive
branches of for instance media like the
one we're in you you is not gonna work
unless women are at least equally
represented so thank you very much to
all of you for being with us today and
thanks to all of you for tuning in see
you soon
[Music]
you